Plenty to do today.
So
the plan right now is we're going to
check over some of the experiments which
I think have some mixed results. Uh
we're going to queue up some new
experiments
and then I think I'm just going to port
a model probably Mingru because it's
easy to C++
just so we can see some of the speeds
that we can get and then we'll go from
there. That's the plan for now.
So we have um this is still a prototype
right
on
all cache. So this is
okay. So for mining
I would like to fix this score thing.
This kind of bothers me that this
doesn't work.
Like these numbers are all messed up
obviously, right?
Oh, 2 E
2F.
Oh, cuz it's this one, right?
What's this? Percent
What is this?
Like why is it like this?
Okay. So, this is 800 at least.
Wait, wait. 8 + E
2.
No.
That I What the hell is wrong with this?
Hey mechanics.
Whoops.
We are uh going to analyze some results
from the overnight experiments. We're
going to launch some new ones and we're
going to implement
uh a new net into the C code and we're
probably or the C++ code and we're
probably going to see if we can get
stuff to go really really fast.
That is the general idea.
Okay. So, these are some numbers.
But why uh why is this being so stupid?
Hello. Yes.
Hang on.
Let me see what you're doing.
This out of the way.
Would it be worthwhile committing my own
GPU driver?
Same interface is multipprocessing.
Oh, we have an example on this, man. So,
uh, this is one of the things that I'm
considering doing with 40. I'm not sure
I'm going to do it, but if I do it, I'm
going to do it very well. I have like a
really cool idea for letting you run the
uh the exact same end code in C and in
uh CUDA.
Let me show you.
We actually have this working uh in 40
for like one very dumb environment.
It's not basically the same at all. It's
actually much simpler,
presuming that you're not doing double
buffering, which makes a lot less sense
than it does on CPU.
Okay, so we have puffer lib CPP,
right? And then look how simple the um
the rollout loop is here.
So this is the whole roll out loop.
Yeah. Yeah. The code is running in
CNCUDA.
Oh yeah, this code running in CUD. Yeah.
So it is basically the same. Um I don't
think there's a good thing that exists
for this yet. But if it does, if it
doesn't and I make it, it's going to be
called Barracuda.
Uh
so here's the step environments in CUDA
function, right?
And the way that this works.
Yeah, exactly. Right. It's worth doing
just for the name.
So here you go. So here's the logs in
CUDA. Here's the bindings that launch
the kernels,
right? Here's creating the ends.
And then this is all exactly the same as
the C except it's cooland instead of
rand. And you also have these device
tags.
So I'm trying to think of the like least
disgusting way to make this just reuse
the same code. Um,
but you can see it's like pretty much
identical.
So, if you want like an example to hack
on, you can work on this. It's going to
be way more stable in about a week.
Depends how fast I do it.
Hey, Carlos. So, today I'm going to be
looking at I have about a thousand
experiments uh results from overnight
and I'm going to look at the Mamba
results. I'm going to look at the mining
results and hopefully we're going to
make some decisions about what to do
with nets going forward or at least
launch some more experiments and then
not be blocked for the rest of the day.
Probably like implement one of these
networks at least so I get some of the
Perf comparisons, see if I can hit 10
mil steps per second, that kind of a
thing.
I got to do an article at some point to
like keep the growth going, but I don't
know. I'm kind of focused on the tech
right now.
It's been awesome the last couple weeks.
We are at 4,100 stars on the puffer.
Puffer is being wellfed.
Right. What was I doing here? I was
trying to figure out why the heck my uh
my rendering is totally screwed up.
Yes, thank you. I do appreciate that. It
actually it helps me quite a bit because
I just get to spend less time on
advertising and more time actually doing
this stuff.
You know, right now we've got we've got
a couple main clients right now with one
thing like lined up coming forward and I
get to spend a pretty minimal portion of
the time on that and I mostly get to do
dev which is good.
How many steps it to take depends on the
end.
By default though, we'll try something
between 50 and 200 million steps.
Some of them are much harder and go
billions or tens of billions or hundreds
of billions.
Thanks for free consultation and code.
Yeah, I mean it's uh open source is
pretty great, right?
It's kind of cool how I can just like do
all this and genuinely just push the
field forward and not completely screw
out screw myself out of the ability to
also monetize portions of it in a way
that like literally nobody's mad about,
which is kind of cool.
Puffer Libs is a wrapper.
It is not just a wrapper library for
environment processing. Huffer does much
much more than that these days. Pretty
much a comprehensive effort to fix the
whole field. Um, so we do our own
environments, we do our own algorithms,
we do our own training implementations,
we do our own infrastructure, we kind of
do everything.
And we run more experiments than I'm
pretty sure any other lab at this point.
Maybe Google has some internal stuff,
but they'll always tell you they do,
even if they don't. I think other than
that we run more RL experiments than
anyone else.
Mhm.
Right up to 20 mil. Yeah, but you can't
just like push batches that high, right?
Cuz like there's only so much variance
in the gradients. You actually need to
optimize more than just super high
batch. Total volume of experiments.
Yeah, exactly. You just get reps in. But
that and that's going up in the next
update, right? That's going way up in
the next update. you know, the stuff I
have in beta right now, you can do
pretty decent like 1,200 experiment like
one node, one multiGPU node uh sweeps
overnight. And it's and this is before
all the Perf optimizations have landed.
So, it's going to be like thousands of
experiments per node per day.
Time per step varies. Uh if your NV is
slow, then yes. Otherwise then it mostly
varies um on the size of the network and
the architecture.
Oh, yeah. This You haven't seen anything
yet, man. Here, I'll show you real
quick. There's still some bugs in it.
Um,
grew.
All right, there you go. This is what
I'm working on for the next update.
We're going to have the best
visualizations in RL.
You're going to be able to check any end
you like.
Let me bring this over. any end that you
like. You know, you can just get
whatever. You can do learning rate. You
can just like craft whatever 3D you have
the same in 2D.
Um, you know, you have like whatever you
like here.
You've got t-nees.
You actually can like you've got tool
tips on everything. You've got filters
on stuff.
L.75.
Got all sorts of filters on stuff
and it's all in C. So, this is going to
be on the website. It's just going to
load like 2 megs of static data and then
you're going to be able to play with the
biggest data set ever released of RL
experiments in your browser. That's
going to be fun.
Oh, the old graphing stuff, dude. I was
just prototyping it.
All our stuff's in Ray Lab.
It's kind of funny to me how he got a
bunch of these gold sponsors since he
put these up.
I kept telling him to put these on the
site.
Now he has. Now he gets Is he doing
better now? Let's see.
Where's the sponsor button? I want to
see if he's doing better.
This doesn't seem right unless he lost
some sponsors.
I thought I got him over a thousand with
uh with my addition.
Oh, it doesn't show cuz I'm not logged
in.
And that guy needs to get a lot more
recognition for his project. Ray Lib is
so good. How much does platinum? He
doesn't have a platinum.
Oh, yeah, he does. Wait. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. Plat. Uh, I mean, he didn't put a
price. I just said I asked him like,
"What's your best individual sponsor?"
And he said like 25 bucks. So, I said,
"Okay, let me just 10x that." I think I
give him like 250 a month or something
if I recall.
I don't know. I really didn't think
about it as like an ROI thing. It more
than anything, I was just like, "Dude,
what the [ __ ] Why is why are you not
getting anything on this project? Like I
get way more out of it than that. Here,
have at least something.
Yeah.
Oh, I mean it's just the sponsor slot,
right? Like I don't um I don't like ask
him for anything custom or anything.
Basically just here's some money. Put a
puffer on a site.
and spend more time developing.
Groceries for whatever are on me.
Like, can I see what's wrong with this
thing? I'm trying to figure out why this
is not rendering the tags correctly. Cuz
I'm trying to use this for my new
vizuali uh my new viz and it's like
doing this weird dumb [ __ ] here.
It's like cropping it to a fixed number
of characters, which should tell me what
the bug This
this.
Why would it be that?
Oh,
probably this crap, right?
Yeah, Ray is very very simple. It's what
we use for all our projects, man.
So if you're looking at like all the
rendering that we're doing, it's all in
Ray. Really easy to get into.
Oh, I'm sorry. I missed your earlier
thing on this. Do you ever think about
implementing rollout monitoring or is
that already exist? If you mean like
watching it live. Um,
I could do it locally. I do have like
there are labs that use our stuff and do
this with wander or whatever.
uh you tend to accumulate an utterly
stupid amount of data very quickly
though. I've actually kind of been doing
the opposite where instead of
integrating [ __ ] with like these stupid
slow providers that can't handle any
data anyways. Uh, so constellation just
saves each experiment to a very small
JSON and then there's just like a post
process that you can use to compress it
even more and then you just load up one
super small JSON into everything and we
kind of just give you like a bunch of
metrics and
um if you want to do like if you want to
monitor checkpoints basically you would
just do load model path on a specific
checkpoint and watch what's happening.
If I combine that with uh like the
virtual frame buffer and the gift saving
stuff, uh then you can probably get that
to do headless uh as well. Headless
rollout monitoring. I actually I did
this for NYU recently. So NYU has a
script for this. I didn't integrate it
into Puffer. I did give it to Drive
though. Hang on.
I'd actually take a PR to get this into
um our like Python bindings for the CMS
if I could do it.
Uh
drive.
Where is it? Puffer drive kit.
It's one of these. Uh you but you were
asking about something else. I'm That's
what I'm doing for monitoring the
graphs. I meant something that renders
the agent behavior storing every OBS obs
and save an epoch.
Um,
it's just a ton of data, man. I guess
like
yeah, the thing is you don't render from
obs, right? You render from state.
Uh, you'd have to save video for it
instead of doing a trace.
That's basically the same as doing
checkpoints, but instead you'd be like
saving a video over training. It would
be cool. I agree. It would be really
cool. It probably would get some
attention as well. It's kind of
I just kind of haven't bothered because
it's such a pain to have that in. Um, it
is probably a good idea though.
Yeah, your obs are pixels. See, I'd have
to basically I'd have to have an NN vin
Rayib that has the headless rendering
and has a fallback so it doesn't [ __ ]
break when you don't have a virtual
frame buffer or whatever because Ray
doesn't have uh doesn't do native head
like true headless. Um
I'd have to also make sure there's not
perf overhead. There's like a ton of
[ __ ] I'd have to actually do for that to
make it work nicely.
white lines. Oh, yeah. So, this is kind
of the the cool thing with
constellation. Um, so we're looking for
runs that have similar hyperparameters
that do well on a ton of different ends.
So, like the idea here is like, hey,
here's this point. This is probably
breakout or whatever. You can see it for
sure if you click like here. This one is
breakout, right? So, this is probably
breakout. And then if you go over here,
this is 2048.
over there like their pong and then
these are runs with similar hypers that
do also do very well or do approximately
as well.
You can kind of like get stable
hyperparameter regions and you get
constellations
buffer constellation.
I don't know the in I got a couple
sources of inspiration for this thing
aesthetically.
Um, it also turns out that it's really
really nice to be somewhere that doesn't
have light pollution.
Like the sky is actually kind of
awesome. We sort of forget that cuz like
it just there's freaking light pollution
almost everywhere now, but
it's actually really freaking awesome.
[laughter]
Uh,
that's weird.
Just rendering wrong. Like, is it just
getting straight cut off?
How the heck is this? Not
not running
this figure too, right?
And now I can stop going absolutely
insane over this.
And now we can do
Oh yeah, we can get like this
2048.
Cool. So now we can see the score that
we were getting on 2048, right?
and the cost.
We can see this looks good, but this is
the old version of the game. And we have
this nice curve
up to
26 or whatever 100,
which is actually perf normalized to
one.
Okay.
So we notice that everything is at max
cost
variety of steps
a little bit but everything is at max
cost
and we really are not doing very well at
all. That's like no learning
pretty sure.
Mamba is even worse. And less data for
this.
Something's just broken.
Now I did just go run something on LSTM
default.
Okay. And now we get this here.
And I can just
Um,
yo, where are my data points?
I got to wear my data points, huh?
doesn't look good either way.
Something's definitely broken.
Is definitely broken.
Cool. I guess we got to go figure out
what's broken. Launch some new
experiments. Unbreak things.
Can't set me up like that.
You just cannot set me up like that.
Let me just try going on. Where's this
box? Yeah, this box is good.
I guess there are a few different
possibilities, right?
Possible there's something broken with
the sweep.
I mean, it's possible
A whole bunch of things are possible.
Well, really?
done.
Okay, cool. Let's not get distracted.
I'm a little tired, but let's keep on
point here. Um,
Did you remove your VIN config? No, it's
still there.
right here.
Pretty basic honestly.
The only real indulgence I allowed
myself with that thing was making a
fancy color scheme.
I actually do think that was worth it. I
stare at it all day.
Nice to have something that I like
looking at,
But we're suddenly at 4 million steps
per second somehow.
use those.
Uh,
There's no Sakura. What are you talking
about?
Uh, I have Mamba Mingru and our LSTM
nets. So, the fast one is actually,
funny enough, it's um just our LSTM
samshi. Yeah. So, sami I only really
have for extra Python highlights. I
don't need it that badly though. I could
probably just like, you know, string
replace or string color self and like a
couple other keywords and it would be
fine.
I honestly am sick of writing Python as
well. I just want to write less Python
in general.
Be happier.
Okay. So, I want to understand how the
hell this isn't faster.
Probably just because we don't have a
kernel for the scan yet, right?
Okay, but this feels pretty stable. So
why
why is it not sweeping correctly?
If I just go to
Oh, well, this is an utterly insane
number of M's.
this is supposed to be Kung's config for
solving [ __ ]
I do remember being able to solve this
though. Um,
like to get something decent within 300
seconds,
5 minutes.
too much office work last two days. Last
couple days I've been working on
implementing and testing Mingru and
Mamba as alternative core architectures
and just having a little bit of trouble
with some of the experiments. Now I have
them both implemented. I got a clean
merge into 40 and the goal is going to
be to get at least one of these
implemented into C today so we can start
optimizing.
I want to get up to 10 mill steps a
second. This like 6.7 in Python is kind
of nuts, but this is like with just a
stupid number of environments.
I don't expect most problems to work on
this.
And also something is just screwy with
this config as well.
So I just want to see if it's something
wrong with the env or if it's wrong with
my setup.
do some get some coffee while this is uh
going on. Do a couple sets. Be right
back.
Okay, believe it or not, I actually feel
noticeably better just from that.
Huh?
by
Well, the coffee is feels better. Yeah.
But also the exercise.
Today I'm just doing a little circuit of
uh weighted pull-ups, Smith uh barbell
rows, and um
uh what the heck?
What's the other row? Mid rows. Yeah,
there you go.
>> [sighs]
>> Need to have a strong back to bear the
weight of this [ __ ] field.
Will China win if we sit around doing
nothing? Sure.
Pretty would be pretty embarrassing.
Well, this is now a 15minute sweep or
run.
I really don't care what's happening
with the LLM space stuff.
Just a big rat race.
Okay, so this is what we're supposed to
have
on G 2048
And okay, we have 2048 training now.
4 mil.
Not bad. We got both of these. This one
is not doing well.
Yeah. So, there's definitely something
broken
between these two. So, let's fix that
and then we should be good.
I think that's what it is. I just broke
something in the port. Probably the
optimizer. Realistically, I'll just have
to bring heavy ball back
temporarily.
Shouldn't be that hard.
Be my guess at least. I don't know what
else it would be.
Okay, this is probably what we need as
well.
Yeah. So if this works then we'll just
know it's optimizer
and we will proceed from here.
So here let's see plan for the rest of
today right. Um
I actually can start
I can I can actually start on cool edge
while I'm waiting for stuff like this.
No problem. No need to waste time.
All right.
Yeah. So, we want heavy ball back for
now.
How adjust
little bug with my integration here.
We're going to make uh 40 nice and
stable. We're running experiments. We're
going to decide between Mamba, Mingru,
and LSTMs.
And we're going to make everything fast.
The plan
Okay,
let's comment this and then we're going
to do.
do this and we'll fix it.
I don't know why I didn't do this this
way to start with. I haven't ported
stuff in a while.
So,
this is weird.
Did better than before,
I mean, it's kind of weird to put like a
threeline setup change on that,
though. I assume you're joking.
Obviously, I can't stop you from doing
that.
Yeah. Hey, Kyou. So, [sighs]
at least a decent chunk of it was the
optimizer. I had the wrong uh the
optimizer screwed up, but it's still not
working the same way in 40 and 3 0. So,
I'm wondering if there's like some end
params or if I've just broken something.
Well, I thought it was a problem with
the sweep, but then I went and I swapped
the optimizer because I tried to use
Torch's version of Muon and it just
didn't work. Um, I put Heavy Ball back
and now I've got
I've got on 30 I've got 3840 as the
score from the default and here I've got
1920.
No, I'm using 2048
since you said it was a good test. En
I'm trying to think what else this could
be.
I did mess with the scheduleuler a
little bit, but it should be the same.
Well, I don't know if it's I just went
and I got different scores on 3 0 and 40
and I merged it pretty recently.
So, presumably that's not expected
Yeah. So, I know you changed the perf
access,
but I basically merged in um like a
pretty recent 3 0 into 40.
I'm trying to figure out what I could
have screwed up.
I thought that you'd broken something
before with it, but I don't think you
actually have. I think I messed
something up with the uh the new
version. I'm not positive
cuz like I've got this huge 30 to 40
thing.
I'm trying to think if there like any
hypers or any like settings that could
have been different.
I mean, to give you an idea of what I'm
trying to do, I just need to have I need
to have a couple cleans where um
I mean, this is at least training
correctly now, right?
I'm going to wait for this whole thing.
Break out optimizes. Now,
I tried using torches muon and it like
wasn't anywhere near as good. So, I
might have it configured differently.
2048's harder than Tetris,
but Tetris doesn't Tetris have like a
way spikier learn curve or is that like
changed now?
Okay. I mean, Breakout learns out of the
box at least now.
We'll also see how our mazes stack up.
This min needs like three layers, right?
Yeah. One layer I don't think is going
to cut it.
Oh, holy.
That's cool.
Okay. So, I mean, this is useful,
Kyouung, but they're kind of they're two
different types of baselines here. Like,
how did you get this? How did you get
this set of params? Like did you run a
sweep and then run the result for longer
or do you have it so that your sweeps
can actually launch jobs that are this
long?
Both
Okay. So,
do you have like a max run time? Because
I remember I put a max run time for all
the experiments. Do you have that or do
you have something else?
I get pamper and run it again. Okay.
But you do actually get it. It runs for
that long in the sweep and you run it
again to confirm.
Okay. Well, then that's definitely what
I want to have set up. Um
because I need to do that exact thing
now. Um,
so I have I have a bunch of GPUs spare
and I want to get reasonable sweeps of
uh the default to make sure I haven't
broken anything in 40. Duh. Um, Mamba
and Domin.
So, I mean, if we can get like
say we do breakout 2048 and Tetris,
I think that's already going to give me
a lot of confidence.
And that's what that's nine GPUs worth
of experiments.
So, we can totally do that, right?
getting 2048 in order. Okay. Well, we
don't have to launch that right yet. if
I just need to get something cuz I'd
like the so basically the quicker I have
an indicator that I'm like mostly sure
of the better because
I'd like to at least know before I spend
a huge amount of time optimizing C++
trans like C++ implementations. I'd like
to have a good idea of which
architecture we're going to ship in 40.
Um, I guess I can technically support
all the backends, but like some of them
are pretty complicated and they all need
custom kernels now for the level of perf
we're targeting in 40. So, um, it's
actually like a fair bit of work. Um,
even when I have like I have a couple
kernels that I can just use existing for
these, but it's still going to be a fair
bit of work. So, like my goal here to
give you an idea, Kyouung, for this
week, um I'm trying to replace the LSTM
cell with something that uh I can get to
run faster because it won't have the
parallelization constraints. Um
and the two candidates are Mamba and
Mingru. I have them both implemented.
They're both like reasonable. They're
both stable enough. And yeah, we just
need to have some comprehensive checks
on them now at this point.
Uh, this shouldn't be Tariq. I have zero
dropped frames right now.
Even try Twitch.
bigger default.
Yeah. So, Tetris is good.
I have it pretty simple to run the
sweeps as well. Now, are you still doing
like single GPU sweeps on all these or
you using our multiGPU sweeps yet?
Custom deeper nets. Ah, I see.
When you say custom deeper nets, did you
mess with the encoder or did you mess
with the LSTM? Because we could also
just do deeper LSTM
single. Okay. H well, you've been doing
some good work on this, that's for sure.
So, let's try then in that case, we can
mess with Tetris.
Um,
if you're doing architecture work as
well, like that's really cool and I'm
going to want to see some of that stuff
cuz ideally we're just going to have the
network size be part of the sweeps going
forward, right?
We already do that on hidden dim and I
can now do it on layers and stuff as
well.
And then my job's going to be getting
all this stuff into C++.
I think this is good enough to run
to run a Tetris sweep at least.
I'll show you what I have for this then.
But pretty much it's just this
these extra params.
Well, we'll put them in the defaults if
we end up keeping them. Obviously,
deeper nets seem to work well for harder
problems like PHC. Kung, I don't trust
that repo at all. And I don't mean your
code. I mean like the original [ __ ]
that's in that. I just don't trust
anything from there
cuz I've I've tested deeper nets like so
many times and it doesn't seem like it's
always just a clear win. It seems like
there's something to it, but it's not
just like a clear easy thing to do,
you know?
Okay. So, we do something like this,
right?
For Tetris.
Oh, the net.
Theh net.
If this works, dude, something is [ __ ]
up. Like,
this doesn't even have skip connects or
anything.
Well, you keep doing this and we will
test this against some other stuff
cuz like I'd be interested to see like
does this do better than just using two
or three LSTM layers
because we can do that as well.
RAM wise is comparable to two. This is
comparable to 256.
Really?
Oh, cuz you kept this 128. Hm.
R LSTM is single layer, but we can do
multilayer. Keep in mind single layer
solved Dota, but we can do multilayer.
I added it yesterday. It wasn't any big
deal. I took it out like before because
like nobody was using it and it didn't
seem to help. But maybe now it does.
For mining, you need multilayer
because Mingru is a weaker network
architecture. You need to stack it a
little bit.
Yeah. Do you do G2048? That'll be a good
one.
And then do you have a cut off in here?
Like am I is this correct here? like to
have a 300 second cut off like this.
I can use this for sweeps if this is
good.
3600. And then this doesn't like how do
these experiments not take absolutely
forever? It doesn't just launch like
crappy experiments. You have like the
pruning in or whatever.
cool. Well,
let me see if this runs.
you put your hidden size one here. This
is actually fine.
And 256 was the best ultimately. Right.
So, can I cut this down?
Yeah.
There's an OM
pick invert.
Yeah, I got LSTM 512 to be better on um
neural MMO. That's the only spot where
it's hard Enough.
All right.
Go grab a tiny box
multiGPU might look. If you can get
anything to work on neural MMO 3, I will
be very impressed. It's quite hard, but
maybe with your new stuff it will, man.
Neural MMO 3 is the end where it's like
if you beat this, it's like, okay, you
rock.
Though mind you, as soon as we beat
Nurmo3, I have to disappear for two
months to write Nurmo 4.
You won't stream its dev.
Oh, no. I'll stream it dev, but like
from all the other stuff. I mean,
I have a lot of other things to do other
than just write neural MMO, right?
Huffrey Isaac Game Company.
I don't know. We might be, man. We might
be
Do we have a max on breakout?
A max cost?
Hopefully I don't get rate limited by
stupid Neptune.
Okay, that's uh six sweeps
trying to learn longer or faster without
crashing.
We should probably figure out the whole
crashy thing.
Snake reward.
Why does it say snake reward?
I see.
So I think um
I think this is actually going to be
pretty related then Kyouong since you've
been doing architecture stuff. Uh the
main thing I've been doing lately on
that is just the core cell right so
whether we use an LSTM or like a mining
or Mamba layer.
Technically I could do LSTM. Um, I could
any of these I can make faster than we
have now. I But I'm going to have to
write kernels is all. So, I get to just
jam some GPU dev. You know,
Yeah, the target the uh the perf target
for puffer uh puffer 4 is 10 million
steps per second just flat without even
going to 16k ends. I want 10 million
steps per second.
Yeah, but Kyouong, the goal is so
basically the goal is we move up the
puffer like update chain
um is going to be that we have
like it's less important that we have
the M's being heavily reward engineers.
It's more important that we have curves
like this where it's like this clear
like it takes quite a bit of compute to
actually do well on the env um cuz like
mainly we're testing general
enhancements, right? And like there's
actually general curriculum stuff that I
can apply across all ends um that I have
planned for probably puffer 5.
All things are in here. They get 65k
tiles is pretty nutty to be fair. That
would be pretty nutty.
So I think then the plan is if these run
uh you'll have 2048 at some point. Uh
and if these all run then this should
give us a pretty decent at least
preliminary indicator
uh of which of these is any good
provided that we don't have dumb things
happen. Uh, I'll keep monitoring them.
And
then I think that leaves me with what,
like the whole rest of the day to do uh,
Perf optimization. So that would
probably be porting. It's probably the
easiest thing is just for me to port
Mingru
since that one uh, like that one I can
get in BF-16 without even writing
kernels.
I have 20-year-old Dell laptops with one
gigabyte.
You're going to hate selfplay. 40% SPS
tank.
Uh, it shouldn't be a 40% SPS tank,
Jess. It should be a
like roughly 10% SPS tank.
Dude, those don't even run like modern
drivers now. Kind bird.
Break out Tetris.
Uh, grid is also very good. I don't know
if you've played around with the maze
kung, but it has configurable difficulty
and um it's like a very sparse M. It's a
pretty good test. Has built-in
curriculum.
Spencer, that's the number.
Yeah, I know. That's not going to be for
long.
Okay, here's the plan. I've got a whole
bunch of dev to do on this. So, we're
going to jam some uh we're going to port
Mingru to C++. We're going to jam dev on
that. And then because that one doesn't
have a CDN kernel, uh we can try BF16 on
it. And hopefully that's enough to get
us 10 mil. We'll see.
Trading curve seem to be weird for grid.
Grid's been pretty consistent, man.
Curriculum 5 just go look up Go Explore.
Not exactly the same thing, but it's
related ideas.
Um, pretty much the idea is that the
next set of algorithm improvements are
going to be uh will have to be enabled
by changes to how we do simulation.
Generally,
it's not going to be like us doing super
clever math. It's more so like we change
the way we write sims in order to get
better training data out of them.
Okay,
three quick sets of back and then that
will wake me up and we will get some dev
in.
All right.
Some good back training.
It actually helps. Wakes me up actually.
You do the right exercises.
I haven't done mid rows in a while. They
feel great.
I guess it's a low row. Yeah, it's a low
row. Never mind. Still feels good.
right.
Just for a little bit
Oh, I did it twice.
That's okay.
Yeah, we're going to have to make this
code like much better. The C++ is just
gross.
Shitty language.
now we have to get this section.
Should be very similar.
I actually think that if I don't over
complicate crap,
it'll actually be way simpler if I just
don't over complicate crap for no
reason.
I do,
but you're like not even a particularly
advanced troll.
So, if you can't troll properly,
you may as well sit down, shut up, and
learn something.
cool dev, you know,
this cool dev.
Currently have a parallelizable
recurrent architecture that I'm porting
to C++. We're going to have Vflip 16.
We're going to have custom kernels. A
lot of stuff that's cool,
you know.
because he'd been too busy trolling.
You listen, there'd actually you'd have
some idea of this
by now.
You hang out around here a lot like
enough time.
Give me a project to make.
Look, I have the content right here.
Has anybody PR Flappy Puff?
I've given this to so many people. I
don't know if anybody's actually PR it.
Yeah. So, somebody PR like just this
version, which was like the really
trivial version,
but you could PR like the actual version
of Flappy Bird.
This is a reference even, though.
Probably not a particularly high quality
one.
Actually, not bad.
Guy didn't do a terrible job. Not bad.
Can't not be programming for a month
though. That's ridiculous.
Oops.
Definitely
Yeah. Does this thing actually work
though? It never does.
Plus Y.
Okay. I have not actually tried it on
this machine before.
I swear this [ __ ] never works. But here.
So it would be plus Y. No provider.
And then you do like this.
See,
I guess it's plus equal.
Okay, let's see if I can get it to work
in 5 minutes.
that work. I don't know. I don't think
that worked.
It's the fact is it's not that I've just
been too dumb to invest five minutes.
It's that I've invested five minutes
like five separate times and I've like
on different machines and it never
[ __ ] works.
Okay. Does not detect the OS clipboard
then.
I hate that we resort to LLMs for docks
for [ __ ] that should exist now.
Oh, there we go. Is it literally just X
clip?
I mean, it's like I feel myself getting
more and more [ __ ] every time I do
[ __ ] like this.
And like, look, now I have something
that does not work over SSH as well.
Yay.
Like, how the hell do we need X11 for a
clipboard? That makes no sense.
You know what? Since you're here, I'll
try this. My gut tells me not to [ __ ]
with this, though. Oh, wait. No, this
doesn't.
Damn it.
We get it working locally at least. I
think the juice is not worth the squeeze
on the rest of that.
It's like terminal dependent as well is
the annoying thing.
And now I completely forgot what the
[ __ ] I was doing.
Um
Yeah, I think I was just fighting this
thing.
I'm trying to get this to be 10 mill
steps per second.
Oh, right. Quen gave me some total
[ __ ] answer, right?
Why am I using Quinn in the first place?
Because this watch
Oh, wait. What?
Oh, yeah. See why does this [ __ ]
direct me back to this.
Oh yeah, right. This page. So this is
what they're calling the docs.
Does this not sound like um
looks like it should work, but it
doesn't.
Let's just
So yeah, Quinn gave me [ __ ] as
expected.
the objective.
So I'm porting mining to uh the C++
version and I'm also in the background
I'm running a bunch of experiments. So
the candidates for Puffer 4 are uh keep
LSTM but write a custom kernel that
actually works with BF-16.
um do miningru which is probably a
simpler kernel and is fully
parallelizable but you have to stack a
couple layers of it to make it as good
it seems so far and then Mambbo which is
hideously complicated and a lot slower
it seems but who knows I got one
recommendation for
This one actually is worth doing.
Uh, where's the freaking thing?
Actually, this one has real docks.
This one is actually worth doing real
quick.
So, this will save me time right now
if I do this.
Actually, I want the latest one for
sure.
Well, actually, I have a reason for it,
which is that they're um Super Maven is
getting deprecated or is getting deleted
by [ __ ] Cursor, who bought it and
killed it in a few weeks. I'm probably
just not going to get another LM
[ __ ] like thing in my editor. I'm
probably just going to go back to LSP,
This is [ __ ] Lua.
Oh, wait. It's inline low. I'm dumb.
I've not used an LSP in
at least a few years.
You wrote the last version of Puffer Lab
in Neovven without LSP.
Um, I have Super Maven for oneline
autocomplete.
But yeah,
how do you check the source code quickly
without an LSP?
What do you mean?
You just can jump around like this,
right?
Um, not like scrolling, but like I don't
know. Uh,
where is it? Puff advantage,
you know.
I honestly don't even want like a bunch
of go to death yada yada like
kind of just want like basic syntax
[ __ ]
Well, actually to be fair, the thing I
want is to not be writing C++ and be
writing C. But we can't have what we all
want now, can we?
Usual size of LSTM 128 to 512.
Usually 128 or 256.
Okay, this is just like Python mixed
with CPP.
So, uh, that's not going to work.
I would need Torch to have a a back end
that like obviously do CUDA C++, but
like if Torch just had a pretty much
minimal C back end.
I mean, it's way easier to not like [ __ ]
up syntax in uh C than C++.
C++ just has so much [ __ ]
Some form of autocomplete is nice,
but I could totally see a non LLM one. I
could see just like some basic heristic
thing
that's linked to an LSP.
Yeah, that's the other annoying thing,
man.
It's like they just start implementing
[ __ ] in Python.
[ __ ] Rust. No.
Hell no.
I'm probably going to start doing more
GPU stuff soon, but guess what it's not
going to be? It's not going to be
[ __ ] Triton. Um, it's not going to be
Kix or like any of the intermediate
layers. It's just going to be write some
straight CUDA cuz that's actually
easier.
Is there a language I don't hate? C. I
don't hate C. C isn't perfect, but it's
pretty damn good. The best programmer I
know writes everything in Nim, which I
haven't used, but it seems like okay.
I'd have to try it.
Zigg seems like moderately okay. I don't
really need a lot of the stuff that it
provides, but it seems like okayish,
better than C++ at least.
I actually don't hate Python. If you use
it for like if you use Python where
Python is good, I don't hate it. Um I
hate Python when you try to make
everything Python or when you have like
big projects where you're mixing a ton
of like extensions and it just doesn't
play nice at all.
I don't have a use for Golang. It seems
fine, but it's like two in the middle,
right?
Rust syntax is not chill at all. Rust
forces you to completely change the way
that you write code uh in order to
prevent a class of bugs that is not even
a problem. So no, [ __ ] Rust.
I don't want immutable everything by
default either. I want mutable
everything by default.
Like the functional dogma is just
stupid. It's like that's how you write
slow code.
Like basically I just want like the
simplest possible way to write
performant code, right? which C gets
really damn close to. Um, there are a
few things I don't like in C. Uh, string
processing in C is just terrible. Um,
there are a few points in C where it's
like, why the hell does this compile?
This should not be part of the lang.
Like, this should not be part of the
spec that this compiles. Um,
you know, there are a few other things,
but for the most part, I really like
what I have.
What is wrong with this? Why can't I
call forward?
Why not using a
Do you mean why am I not using assembly?
Okay. So, this is supposed to work just
this way.
because you can't actually write like
you cannot actually write large projects
in a reasonable fashion with assembly
and know the one counter example of
roller coaster tycoon doesn't count.
Oh, it is like this, isn't it?
Are you kidding me? You have to do this.
That's kind of awful.
Okay,
I didn't believe that.
>> Well, yeah, but have you ever heard the
phrase exception that proves the rule?
You got any um
you got any other candidates for uh LSTM
cell replacement?
What do you mean so many hours on end?
Really not that many hours.
Can you only program for a maximum of 4
hours like ever on a good day when you
have a new project that you're
interested in
or are you just like burnt out?
Uh, the window manager thing really
isn't a big deal. Look, I had a super
tryh hard setup in undergrad. It really
doesn't matter that much.
Oh,
I mean, like, do you have a good diet?
Do you get sleep? Do you exercise? I
can't even get four hours of programming
if I'm like off of my schedule.
If I'm like off, it basically I may as
well just not do anything that day.
Whoever came up with that syntax needs
to be shot.
Couple
takes two top tensors,
this does feel [ __ ] Like the C++ API
does not feel good to use.
Like when I say I enjoy C, I can
actually build stuff very quickly and
have pretty much I know exactly what I'm
doing at all times.
This [ __ ] is just like guessing the
black magic box cuz there's just a
million things going on for no apparent
reason.
Oh, yeah. I don't do that.
I do get up to do sets occasionally when
I feel like it, which I should do in a
moment actually.
Oh, lovely. It's just a disgusting
lovely. Yeah. Okay, cool.
Very nice. Good job, stupid.
home gym, servers,
pretty much everything.
I got to go do a few back sets in a
minute here.
compiles.
Cool.
Um,
well, given that this actually compiles,
that's perfect timing. There's a
restroom real quick. I'm going to do a
few back sets and get my coffee and then
we will attempt to get this thing
running end to end.
And it's not going to be like crazy
crazy fast to start with, but it does it
is going to let us get BF-16
um and have some proper experiments
without without having screwy kernels to
deal with.
[sighs]
I'm woken back up.
So, um,
we mostly do high performance sims for
companies
and then we train agents on them as
They're absolutely serious competitors,
especially if the US is going to [ __ ]
around as much as it is at the moment.
few finance people liberty one animation
thing some core research probably
starting some stuff in games soon we
really don't have um like specific
covered areas
we do general purpose reinforcement
learning right
that's our whole thing
I'd like to do stuff in medical if
there's uh the ability to build Sims
there.
I mean, probably the problem I care most
about overall is
uh at least in the medium term is that
right
aging and disease?
What do you mean the US is [ __ ]
around right now?
bunch of giant companies.
A lot of them are like [ __ ] around
with like this government stuff, trying
to like jockey for political
um political position and like
government support instead of actually
doing the damn research correctly. Um
we're leaving on the table like a ton a
ton a ton of stuff. It's very myopic.
It's very rat racy at the moment.
um
it's not very consolidated in the sense
that you have a number of major players
that are all kind of racing to do the
exact same thing. A little of that is
good, but too much of that really isn't.
Um
what else?
um the actual threat of there being
regulation in part of because of like
the companies [ __ ] around lobbying
with for dumb stuff. Um whereas China is
just not going to have any and is not
going to care. Enthropic I believe had
to pay a giant suit uh over books.
That's just not going to happen in China
because they don't give a [ __ ]
I do think that the um
the western approach is generally better
on like breaking new ground in
innovation,
but
that's not to say that there isn't
plenty of it in China. And I think that
China is generally much better at like
once there is the like the core
breakthrough is done uh stacking all the
incremental
uh progress on top of it in order to
make it really really work well. Uh
they're just way better at that because
they just have a ton of people and they
work really hard.
There is definitely a lot of [ __ ]
about and if you kind of want to like
see that if you just go to SF and talk
to some of the people they're just like
the most outofouch insufferable people
you will ever meet a good chunk of them.
And a lot of that is defining the
culture of a lot of these labs.
like Open AI was decent about that and
then they got a bunch of crazies and
then the crazies left to do anthropic
and then they got some more crazies and
now I have no idea. Anthropic's always
been nutty. Um X is crazy in the other
direction and they're also missing some
stuff, but they're doing generally
pretty well. Um but they're behind on a
few core things.
Facebook is just [ __ ]
Uh Microsoft is like a meme
and Google is generally doing Google
things which means like throwing 10
times as many people as you would
reasonably need at a thing but then
getting it done as a result of like
sheer force. Probably not in the most
efficient way possible.
Um, probably makes it a hell of a lot
harder for individuals to do much there,
but
yeah, the pure just we're going to
outscale is like they found one. It's
like one trick pony, right?
Uh, no. EU has always just been
gigafucked.
I think like a couple companies like
Mistl and whatever will probably do like
AI for Europe or whatever, but they're
not going to lead.
Europe has decided to be a backwater by
virtue of their governance.
basically the government overhead in
getting [ __ ] done in the US like
compared to China. That gap times 10 is
the EU.
I think it's probably like if you're an
average person without any particular
ambitions, there are definitely parts of
the EU that are a better place to live
than in the US. But at the forefront,
nah, you're just [ __ ] You get pounded
down to the ground.
How dare you try to do anything?
Shitty culture
or that at least. Shitty culture for
progress.
Well, yeah, it's the regulation, but
then I mean, who's voting for it, right?
Oh yeah, I'm not disagreeing with that,
Lucas.
And many of them come here, right?
Parties appoint all the representatives
themselves.
Well, then you can't really do anything
but just get out of there.
It's just latestage governance.
No,
this is not um
I really try hard not to comment on
anything political that's not directly
like AI policy or whatever here.
Um
cuz like you're just not going to change
[ __ ] doing that, right?
Like the thing that you can do is just
say like, "Hey, by the way, here's some
sci-fi tech. It exists now. It's
everywhere. Anybody can run it and use
it. So, you're just going to have to
deal with that. And you can't, you know,
there's no possible way that you can
screw that up.
And it's still like it's still nowhere
where it needs to be, right? Like in in
my mind, in an ideal world, if you were
a world-class scientist who's just like
doing awesome research and outputting
really cool work, money should just be
falling out of the sky for you, right?
There's still this huge gap to
commercialization that's this very ma
major impediment to progress. Um there's
this major gap with like legal and
regulation and other barriers in the way
as well. Um, but hey, it's better here
than anywhere else pretty much with the
exception of China having fewer barriers
in some places and more in others. But,
you know, that comes with a cost.
So the vibe like the whole vibe projects
thing is simultaneously good and bad. So
it's like it's one it's a good thing
that individuals can do more stuff. Uh,
it's a bad thing that it seems like
at least a very large chunk of people
just use this [ __ ] as an excuse to not
learn anything and to shift higher and
higher into levels of abstraction, which
basically guarantees like more and more
inefficiency in anything that you build.
the next Terrence Tao is not going to be
like, "Oh, I vibe coded a thing."
Like, there's going to be this very
narrow period of time in which like you
can do stuff like this and oh, it's
cool. And then after this, I think
people are just going to realize that if
you don't know the underlying details,
you simply have zero value over the AI,
right? Because like the like the very
stupid loop of you saying, "No, not like
that. Do it this way. Do it that way."
Like that's just going to be automated
and you will just have zero value,
which is not a bad thing. That's the way
it's always been, you know, zero effort,
zero value.
Going lower level
mostly.
Nah, it's just they haven't gotten the
form factor right and the models are too
[ __ ] stupid, right? Like the thing is
this is going to be amazing for
education if you want it. Um once it
needs to be a bit better, it's going to
take a couple more gens of models and
then like there'd actually have to be
somebody incentivized to package it that
way instead of just like packaging stuff
to make [ __ ] as lazy as possible. But
like you could imagine having a model
that is like me sitting uh looking over
your shoulder and just like giving you
feedback when you need it on stuff in
real time and like being able to just
ask questions and have them answered
like with full context. Um which is not
the way it is now. The way it is now is
much more like handholdy do it for you.
not like you know how do I be an
effective teacher
>> and then there's also like there's just
too much like stuff that isn't worth
learning like oh I'll let the LM do it
because it's not worth learning like
this API for instance is dog [ __ ] like
but the correct sequence here should not
be well LLM will do it for me it should
be what we just should have an API for
like the most central thing in the
entire field like a low-level API that
doesn't suck, right? And somehow we're
in a state where there isn't On.
really.
That's weird.
This is different. There's never been
like there's never been a credible
attempt to automate intelligence itself.
Like all these like all these historical
analogies are just stupid at this point
like like
I don't think that because of language
models the state of the world is going
to get to be like oh they're so much
smarter. It's so complex like people
can't do anything. But it absolutely can
get to the state of the world where it's
just like a really really big company
where we've just like [ __ ] heaped on bad
engineering and like nobody can actually
go through it manually anymore. So like
basically you could end up having like
crucial projects that it would be
imagine you get the average Google
engineer and you just get like a 100red
billion of them to build something like
you get something like that where as an
individual there's nothing you can ever
do even though maybe that same project
could have been built at like a 10,000th
of the scale and would just be better.
to like the types of bad outcomes that I
think about are pretty different from
like the
oh Hollywood do may I whatever like a
lot of the stuff that's just discussed
just is just so stupid.
That's why I don't bother engaging with
it because it just draws it just
attracts stupid people.
It's way way way more effective to just
like spend your time thinking about and
building good low-level tech that just
demonstrates, hey, at least this section
of science is going to be carved out
where things are simple, they are fast,
they work, and there's no bloat on top
of it. And now actually people can do
stuff with it and understand it, right?
It's not about education. Plenty of them
are highly educated. They're just stupid
Where do you meet the most cracked
engineer so far?
Um, random places.
Like totally random places.
tell you sure [ __ ] wasn't at Stanford or
MIT.
How the [ __ ] could we never get that,
dude?
Is this supposed to be concatenated this
way?
It looks like it,
Oh well, this is totally wrong then.
Okay.
Yeah. Okay. It's totally not clear
whether LLMs do it right
alone.
But like
there can't possibly be something so
special about the brain that you can't
do it any other way.
Oh,
[ __ ]
Yeah, there is really something deeply
wrong with the way that these things are
trained,
right?
Maybe I'll go figure out what it is
after I solve our route.
for I mean it depends who you are.
For me in the middle of nowhere with a
lot of land and nobody bothering me.
Got enough bloody stress and activity
and [ __ ] as it is.
Nice to be able to go run in the morning
with just peace and quiet.
That can't possibly make sense though if
you think about But
H.
Oh, 128. It's hardcoded somewhere.
I don't think so.
I don't think it works that way.
this.
Okay. So
I figure this out.
Okay.
Is it going to get to be hidden?
Ah, I see it.
no, Lucas.
I'd feel like an intro interview
and that says a lot more about the
interview than anything else.
I understand.
All is clear to me now.
All is clear.
We can make this work.
Confident
Just going to keep cranking
till we get it.
I'll be right back. Use the restroom.
Get a couple couple arm sets in and
we'll keep going for a little bit before
There.
Cables are great. I really never used to
like cables. Then I got some. And you
know, it's a little different when you
have your own and you can kind of just
screw around and experiment with them
and find good exercises.
I honestly use them more than my
dumbbells now.
It's kind of crazy. have really nice
dumbbells,
I really don't care, man. Lucas, like
it's not the thing that excites me about
AI. Like, oh, we robot butler is not the
thing that I get excited about.
I want AI that tells us how we how we
can reverse aging
and like not have disease be a thing
that exists
and then also make us some other cool
sci-fi [ __ ] you know? Now, maybe we'll
figure out uh room temperature superc
conductivity.
Maybe we'll figure out some like crazy
sci-fi era materials. Cool [ __ ] you
know?
Well, isn't that depressing, man? Right.
That's just cuz we haven't made it cool
enough yet.
use the cool [ __ ] against it. Depends,
man. There's tech that's like
asymmetrically
centralized and there's tech that's like
asymmetrically decentralized,
right?
Hoverboard kind of cool.
Seven out of 10.
Mhm.
That is also cool,
you know.
I don't know the crackpot thing that is
like super obvious to me but that people
still somehow debate me on is like we
should cure aging and disease
and like we're going to look back on the
time before we do this as oh look these
cavemen actually [ __ ] died. Are you
[ __ ] me?
It's going to be one of those. This one
I'm pretty confident on.
But the fact that this is considered
wrong is like by even anybody is just so
incredibly stupid.
It's like, hey, you want to die of
cancer? No. You want to die of heart
disease? No. You want to die of aging?
Oh, yeah. That sounds great.
I guess you do kind of need this. It's
fine.
Oh, I wouldn't say I never said anything
about gene editing, though.
That only solves it for new people.
I want the problem to be solved for me.
Thank you very much.
Who do I look like? Mother Teresa to
you?
I don't know if it's RNA is the thing
you have to edit. You have I think you
have to edit a
Okay. Well, that's got [ __ ] up
somehow.
right, I got to go in a few minutes,
guys. Um,
I'll keep on this until then. But, uh,
for folks watching, I stream pretty much
all this dev. It's all open source.
really trying to just get RL to where it
needs to be already. It's all super
fast. All runs locally. It's a lot
easier to get into than you'd think. And
uh most of the ways to contribute don't
involve the horrible things that you see
me doing half the day. So if you're
interested in that, puffer.ai star the
GitHub. It's free. It really really
helps more than you'd expect. Discord's
where all the dev is. You can join this.
You can also follow me on X. This is
where educational content is and
research as well. Uh, a lot of these M's
are just built by contributors and some
of them ended up being really, really
useful for research. So, yeah, if you
can implement Tetris, you can advance
the state of RL. That's pretty sweet.
back to this for a couple That's
B
and hidden size.
Hello Spencer.
Welcome to the seven circle of hell.
Um, Monday is better or they interrupt
my main work day.
Wednesday's meeting.
Well, as soon as we as soon as the
delivery is done, man, and we discuss a
little bit,
I will have my other one underway by
then as well. I already sent them a
draft for uh scoping.
He well I have to get
yeah he okayed the first milestone but I
have to do the scoping for the second
one and then there's some you know
agreement on that and then we'll sign
that separate All right.
Actually, didn't we have the whole thing
scoped? We scoped all three for them,
right?
So, actually, yeah, it's a very short
thing for uh the one you're doing.
It's a very short thing for the one
you're doing.
I'm working on Mingru and Mamba at the
moment. Like, we're getting it into CPP.
We're going to get it with B float.
We're going to hit 10 million steps per
second. And I actually found a bug in my
mining group uh that was limiting its
effectiveness. So, I think we're
actually going to be able to just crush.
We'll see.
How many work at Puffer Lib?
Well, I mean, everything's through
contracting. So, at the moment, mostly
just doing stuff with Spencer.
We have
We placed one other person.
Oh, and then we have a an intern for the
summer. Pretty
much what I do, man.
Pretty much what I do.
Yeah, I got to go in a minute here,
folks. I think I might do an evening
stream. We'll see. I think I should have
like two or three hours to spare tonight
for an evening stream. So, that'd be
nice. Get some more progress in.
Okay. Well, we're going to finish this
uh after dinner. I'll